bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
d' écran pliable de smartphones pliable
et d'apple parce que oui apple aussi
rentrer dans la cour des smartphones
filiales et ça vous allez voir c'est
super intéressant on va le regarder
maintenant
on a beaucoup parlé des écrans pliables
alors on a parlé du samsung galaxy x
déjà un paquet de fois on l'attend un
peu comme l'arlésienne on sait qui va
arriver on sait pas trop quand on a
parlé ya pas longtemps de huawei huawei
qui pourrait arriver aussi avec un
smartphone pliable j'ai déjà parlé de
lenovo il ya pas mal de marques qui
rentre un peu dans la compet il devrait
y avoir aussi motorola qui arriverait et
puis beaucoup de constructeurs par la
suite parce qu'effectivement après la
grande révolution révolution un des
grands guillemets bien évidemment du
borderless on voit que la prochaine
grande révolution de la téléphonie
mobile seraient des smartphones
complètement pliable avec des écrans
pliables alors on parle pas de pliable
au même sens que l'axonais haine que je
vous ai présenté au ces de las vegas en
début d'année parce qu'effectivement à
l'axone m c'est un écran qui se rabat un
écran vraiment à part qui une fois mis
côte à côte
je vous fais comme une espèce de faux
grand écran parce que vous avez le bord
en plastique au milieu c'est pas
terrible
notre à ce produit fait beaucoup parler
lui donc là on parle pas de ce produit
là on parle vraiment d'un smartphone qui
pourrait être complètement pliable un
iphone complètement pliable alors un
iphone qui n'arriverait pas tout de
suite vous savez apple aujourd'hui il
aime bien innover mais il sonne bien sûr
de zen bien prendre leur temps ils vont
pas se dire on va être le premier pour
sortir le nouveau produit qui va
déchirer
on va le sortir on va d'abord un petit
peu attendre que le marché soit mûr on a
regardé ce soit un petit peu cassé les
dents dessus elle tant qu'on arrivera on
arrivera avec un produit au numéro c'est
une révolution aujourd'hui je vous
présente l'iphone pliable le premier
smartphone pliable l'iphone du futur
voilà c'est un petit peu aujourd'hui le
fonctionnement d'apple
on les sent dans l'innovation toujours
mais avec prudence
alors effectivement ce nouvel iphone
pour arriver dès 2020 ne serions pas
trop pressé mais d'un côté 2020 c'est
presque demain de toute façon pour
l'instant on n'a vu aucun smartphone
plia dans l'état ni en prototype ni
entre commercialisé donc on imagine que
très bien si vous annonçant smartphone
pour 2020 à être très très bientôt 2020
c'est presque demain donc effectivement
on attend pour cette année fin d'année
peut-être un galaxy x voire début 2019
huawei aussi j'en ai parlé à quelques
jours avec un smartphone qui pourrait
arriver probablement l'année prochaine
peut-être cette fin d'année mais je
pense plutôt l'année prochaine hélas cet
iphone qui arriverait en 2020 de tout
façon c'est pas trop pressés parce que
déjà l'année dernière en 2005 ils ont un
petit peu révolutionné leur gamin avec
l'iphone 10 avec un smartphone très
grand écran avec cette fameuse encoches
là haut que tout le monde reprend de
plus en plus ailleurs encore les
résistants mais on trouve de plus en
plus sur android alors effectivement
historiquement apple a vraiment marqué
qu en 2007 en sortant l'iphone
le premier smartphone alors je sais
qu'ils vont me dire apple ce n'est pas
le premier smartphone mais apple c'est
le premier smartphone grand public avec
un aura grand public donc si du point de
vue grand public apple a quand même
marqué le coup et ceux qui ont vraiment
fait rentrer les smartphones dans les
ménages
on part quand même de très loin avec des
espèces de produits comme ça à ces
petits qui à l'époque était magnifique
qui aujourd'hui pour le commun des
mortels sont quand même relativement
moche hein forcément ce sont des
tout-petits téléphone mais c'est normal
ils ont ensuite fait évoluer leurs
gammes pour arriver avec un écran bord à
bord quasi bord à bord et iphone dit ce
n'est jamais qu'une évolution de la
gamme c'est pas une grande révolution
donc si on veut une révolution il faut
aller du produit des smartphones sur des
écrans pliables sur des projets de plus
en plus dématérialisé et pourquoi pas
après du r et bold on n'y est pas encore
tout son or par alors on est un peu dans
la science fiction de la téléphonie
mobile mais c'est des choses sur
lesquelles on va aller pour l'instant ce
qu'on sait c'est que apple a commencé
aurait commencé on sait ce qu'on pense à
bord en tout cas moi ça chez vous dans
la rumeur d'un attendant d'être petit
potin que apple commencé à travailler
dès aujourd'hui sur l'iphone pliable de
toute façon ils sont obligés de passer
par là puisque les concurrents se
positionne et après on peut imaginer qu
effectivement c'est tout un écosystème
qui viennent un tour de ça mais ça aussi
c'est très intéressant lorsqu'il faut
vraiment concevoir c'est que cet iphone
pliable serait à mi chemin entre un
iphone et un ipad une espèce de fable
est made in apple parce que en réalité
votre iphone il est pas très grand même
si vous prenez les grands écrans même si
vous prenez un 8 plus ou si vous prenez
un iphone 10 vous effectivement des
écrans qui sont assez conséquents mais
imaginez un officier doubler voire
tripler la surface
vous retrouverez avec un produit qui
serait à mi chemin entre un iphone et un
ipad et c'est ça qui est hyper
intéressant c'est de se dire
qu'aujourd'hui
apple vous dit pour nous l'ipad ces
ordinateurs du futur on a rajouté un
style et on rajoute un clavier bluetooth
soit la clé smart connector comme sur
l'ipad pro importe au choix toujours est
il que pour eux l'ipad c'est la version
l'ordinateur du futur l'ordinateur
personnel un pas professionnel
l'ordinateur personnel
donc si ils arrivent à avoir un écran
pliable au niveau des smartphones qui
augmente la capacité de lecture
donc pourquoi pas un ipad de poche on
aurait un seul et même produit qui
viendraient unifiée l'iphone et l'ipad
je sais pas ce que vous en pensez mais
pour moi quand l'ipad est sorti en 2010
je me suis dit c'est quoi cette machine
on a déjà les iphone qui sont des
smartphones de poche
là vous avez un smartphone format géant
il faut pas téléphoner avec à quoi ça
sert
alors effectivement il faut comprendre
les mains qu'on manipule on se rend
compte qu'il ya un vrai intérêt que se
produit effectivement très intéressant
c'est qu'on peut faire pas mal de choses
avec et qui vient vraiment trouvé sa
place dans la gamme des produits apple
et que une tablette ce n'est pas qu'un
smartphone géant mais l'idée d'avoir un
écran pliable donc une plus grande
superficie vous permettrait d'avoir un
ipad unifiée avec un smartphone est
quelque chose d'intéressant avec d'un
côté une gamme plus tôt d'entrée de
gamme une gamme plutôt amateur grand
public sont payés ça comme ça avec un
iphone ipad un petit peu classique est
de notre côté un iphone ipad
professionnels plus grand écran ça
serait probablement un iphone pliable
plus avec pourquoi pas un style et donc
on peut très bien imaginer les choses
allant dans ce sens là où alors ou alors
on pourrait prendre carrément le chemin
inverse et se dire apple vous pros vont
vous proposer un produit niña tu risée
garder l'ipad un ipad pliable pourquoi
pas un ipad que vous pourrez rentrer
dans une sacoche plus facilement nan
ipad un produit dédié ipad et de l'autre
côté un iphone dédiée iphone mais avec
un format hyper compact qui prendrait
beaucoup moins de place que les
smartphones actuels moi je prends par
exemple mon 6 s vous l'avez là on va
imaginer qu'il a effectivement se forme
alors si on regarde les vieux modèles la
c3 ges bon c'était déjà plus petits
voitures sur des modèles un peu plus
grand poids dans des grands écrans et
l'idée serait de se dire on a un grand
écran mais sur un truc qui fait la
moitié de ça voyez imaginez ça dans
votre poche dans votre sac à main madame
ça serait vraiment intéressant
je vais le faire tomber par terre tout
va bien il va casser peu importe donc on
pourrait très bien mais cela paraît
chose de plus petit qui prend vraiment
plate on connaît les deux écoles les
deux possibilités soit gardé un format
comme on actuellement avec un plus grand
écran qui ferait un ipad soit un format
plus réduite qu'on ouvrirait pour avoir
informé un iphone y avoir un petit peu
ce qu'est le plus intéressant et le plus
rentable pour le fabricant d'un côté si
vous faut un format un peu plus grand
comme un ipad à ils vont forcément
unifier la gamme donc faire disparaître
d'un côté la gamme ipad pour lui faire
gamme iphone
pas si c'est bien rentable pour eux ou
de notre côté avoir des ehpad qui se
plie des iphone qui se plie mais
toujours les deux produits complètement
séparés ce qui vous permettrait
effectivement cela des ipad qui se
plient devant des plus grands écrans
pourquoi pas d écran 14 pouces 15 pouces
on peut se retrouver comme sur un
ordinateur pliable qui entrerait dans
votre poche
voilà un petit peu pour l'avenir en tout
cas de ses smartphones pliable d'apple
on sait pas quelle forme ils auront on
sait pas à quoi ils ressembleront on
sait qu'ils vont arriver on sait pas
trop quand probablement 2020 mais en
quoi ça ouvre vraiment une bonne
réaction et c'est super passionnant
parce que ces rumeurs elles vous
permettent de sentir les tendances et de
voir ce que va être ce que pourrait être
en tout cas la technologie de demain la
technologie grand public d'ailleurs
marqué moi ce que vous en pensez
qu'est ce que vous pensez être commencé
qu'on aura plutôt des iphone qui se plie
des tablettes qui se plie ou alors
est-ce que l'ipad et l'iphone ou par se
retrouver unifiée au travers des crampes
et fiable vous marquez tout ça comme
d'hab vous invite à vous abonner à
rester connectés parce que pour être
toujours plus d'écrans pliable de techno
deux tablettes de smartphones ya plein
de choses qui va arriver
donc restez connectés bien évidemment
vous me laissez des jolies pouces vous
participez avec tous vos avis que tout
le monde soit au courant et qu'on en
parle qu'on soit plus en plus nombreux
merci à vous on est toujours tout en
gros je suis très content très très très
heureux de pouvoir participer et
partager tout ça avec vous d'ici ces
prochaines vidéos qui va arriver très
rapidement probablement de maman un peu
comme tous les jours on va pas se mentir
d'ici là soyez sages santé vous bien je
vous embrasse un gros gros bisous et à
très bientôt
ciao
[Musique]